[Music]
it took six production companies to make
this movie happen which is always a good
sign at two a 24 did you think after a
terrific run of movies like ex machina
and room you could slip in a subpar
horror movie without any asshole
noticing well I am that asshole
the Levitch also the diagraph of Vivi
was used before the sixteenth century
didn't have a space between the V's and
after the sixteenth century the modern W
was used and this movie is set in the
17th century so my point is this logo
symbols well one way out into this
wilderness to find discount the crucible
I know we're going for an early
colonists look for the costuming but
there's an 87% chance that beanie came
from American Apparel
William and his family are banished from
the plantation because of something
something Jesus things even if you're
trying a subversive take on or make sure
to include those discordant violins and
children singing or you'll be laughed
out of the theatre sudden daytime sudden
prone position grave excitement I know
how this ends with a fetus in space not
only did the family decide to rapidly
rebuild their living space they also had
time to grow farm animals and a pet at
least we know why they keep banging
those kids out free labor I haven't seen
trees this menacing since the happening
[Music]
apparently this invisible clumsy ass
which will disturb the brush when she's
absconded with a baby but during the
actual kidnapping she was Pro ish at not
making noise also if you're an invisible
ass which why are you even concerned
about running away could have taken the
baby and just stood there and there's
nothing anybody could do also the red
Cape in the woods is giving me a much
stronger the village vibe than I think
the movie intended suddenly this which
is visible again and running with normal
human speed this tells me already that
nobody knows what this witch can and
can't do no one will be seated during
the slather your ugly old naked body and
weird pomegranate jam scene also I guess
she's slathering baby guts on her naked
body so that she'll be young again I
wouldn't know since I can't see shit in
this scene and I'm vaguely aroused movie
asks me to watch a baby murder and an
old naked bloody woman do which adorn
self in the course of two minutes and I
am two minutes past saying few movie
brother looking down his sister shirt
that's a sinan tonnison is really just
mildly stirring in her sleep but caleb
wakes her all the way up just to tell
her to go back to sleep Leah
really delights and telling me nothing I
can hear the director now it'll be just
like the revenant only with more corn
and less bare reaps this is no Easter
eyes on a dry guy I got the volume on
this turned up to Michael Bay levels and
it's still hard to hear these people
plus they're speaking in that early
colonial dialect I mean trying to
understand words in this movie is
difficult I may have no idea what's
going on but this movie's pilgrim hats
are on point serious question is all
this movie has to offer a bunch of
creepy soundtracks but set to glacial
zoom shots of nature I love these novel
as well this dialogue is unintelligible
so I'm going to assume it's the type of
dialogue that makes this movie good dad
I'm not much of a hunter but I would
think something is fucked up if a rabbit
just sat there while the dog incessantly
barks at it I'm pretty sure that's
racist if I'm hearing these demon
children correctly 21 minutes in and
other than the old lady naked chick
writhing in the pit for a moment not a
lot of witching just some really steep
pre-colonial parents a stubborn goat and
lots of cloud cover I know the boar and
everything but he doesn't have one
change of clothes dad's really always
one slip and maneuver away from naked
with chopping
also somebody has to chop wood in a
horror movie cliche hang on the water's
flowing downstream from Thomasin who's
cleaning her dad stained outfit in the
brook get Kayla besides this is the best
place for mom's water you know what
would help those kids awkward sexual
feelings towards the sister to go fight
how about could lose me father silver
wine coping this hovel I cannot no place
child we interrupt this horror movie to
bring you a wacky sitcom
misunderstanding also it feels like this
family is cursed when they constantly
engage in real biblical sins like
stealing bearing false witness
peeping down thy sister's shirt and all
that stuff but this is the only family
that's cursed surely there are others
engaging and even worship and they are
bombarded with all the bad witch luck
this movie seems to put on them
thankfully for the sake of this movie in
my own heart nothing bad ever happens in
movies in this kind of Darkness on
remote farms what's the point of the
demon bunny okay demons conduct business
with farm animals that don't require
disguises they can just do their normal
while being invisible right and why a
bunny you must sleep tonight
dad interrupts the prayer even though
she's got one sentence to go Jesus
Thomasson Kayla are ya bet Catherine
thinks that just because her kids don't
answer they can't possibly be listening
to this conversation she she must leave
to have another family was no telephones
kill with as well almost keep him still
and Thomasina unto the village with the
his and thomas in somalia dad changes
his mind about whoring out his daughter
just to shut his wife up for the night
how did this family last long enough to
even grow corn which takes about a year
when i'm also learning how to find kill
pick fish and eat non corn food sources
in this region movie rips off the dog
stop by being a dog distraction from i
am legend dog that is practically dead
manages to Yelp like something just
happened to him even though he's clearly
been hurt for some time and should be
dead but if something did just happen to
him Caleb damn well been able to see it
since he was only like 50 feet away and
walking in a straight line to where the
dog was movie kills a baby in a dog
within the first hour and yet has
generally forgotten to which Thomason
does that kind of knocked out when you
rest your head gently on your arm
this goes on for some time Thomas and
waits until she's directly in sight of
her father before actually saying
something also didn't the two kids leave
before daybreak they could have gotten
far since Thomason heard her dad calling
from outside the woods but now it's
almost night because atmosphere can't
wait for narrative to catch up dammit
discount Angelina Kat Bonham Denning
Jolie Carter which the director couldn't
choose between Ansel and Gretel Little
Red Riding Hood and the three little
pigs for his inspiration and said we'll
use all three also which lures Caleb in
by assuming he's a boob man
when adult which is disguised as
beautiful women kiss pre-adolescent boys
their once beautiful hands turn into
witches hands for the benefit of an
unseen audience during one of this
movies many black screen moments we hear
a thunderstorm because who needs to
foreshadow with restraint all sets up at
first light I'll not return till a
fountain the movies bright the right
bothers me not so it's William going now
we're in the morning and even if the
rain doesn't bother him it would make
Caleb almost impossible to track also
how can there be both a bright moon and
rain she's a Jeju I don't have no horse
not just say tis a five day walk then is
your wife somehow unaware of your not
horse having status enough to the which
put Caleb a year or why did he come back
to the house and decide to lean up
against the fence naked I mean I guess
it's a good thing Thomas and decided to
tend to goats at this very moment in
time or this guy would have died of
pneumonia and that'll teach you to stare
at cleavage young man okay first off
they have no idea what happened to this
boy but they immediately go D let's poke
a hole in his head route second off all
of them apparently know what to do in
this situation you know when you find a
child that's been wandering in the woods
for a couple hours then shows up naked
and comatose in the rain happens all the
goddamn time this is not what what which
cost which good question we're almost
two-thirds through the movie and I've
only seen her twice
well much of the concession in the law
finally good friend Lisa Thomason it's
like I love should adult says Williams
just calling out his to-do list for
tomorrow which involves a doctor's visit
probably picking up some milk and bread
and selling off his oldest daughter to a
new family ravished with his love
towards what a great scene this is they
put it in any other movie not called the
which I might really enjoy it the
director said let's have him puke up an
apple because that is weird and
impossible and creepy and even though
there's only 40 minutes left I really
don't know what I'm doing and so I'm
leaning more toward dis and it scares
the next will plot resolution also let's
have your character vomit an apple
representing Adams original sin that
would make it look like even more of an
asshole
chonus I finish him if she desires your
blood why did she let you go in the
first place did she know you're come
back to life only to die anyway scene
would be good for the movie which
decides to be an evil prankster and give
Caleb enough life to give this family
hope and then kills him it's pretty
disturbing honestly I want to remove a
sin for it but I'm so confused that I'm
adding one I saw the serpents
my son you stop that Brad's a lie I saw
it
Caleb disappeared with thee and then
found him pale is dive naked has sinned
and reached well will ones got all the
evidence he needs no use in checking out
the probably haunted woods that they
forbade the kids to go into also let's
talk about Williams dickhead character
not only did it take his family from a
nice place in England to subsequently
more miserable living conditions he also
let his son take the blame for going
into the woods let Thomason take the
blame for the cop lied to his wife
didn't provide food for his family and
now he's calling his fucking daughter a
witch is this a fact blame the goat for
killing your children was the 17th
century version of blaming your farts on
the dog Gigi make someone holy bummed
without goals I thought that only
happened in Tijuana I suppose I should
be wondering what's going on considering
this father was just acting like he
trusted Thomas and story and distrusted
the twins but is now hammering them all
into a makeshift prison together but
really I'm mostly wondering how this
asshole has to use the blood end of an
axe as a hammer does he not have a
hammer
he has a KERS of corn crops for now
three kids goats an entire house and he
has no hammer week that kids get
punished but black Phillip is still
alive even before they find out he's the
devil that goats a total asshole does
seriously this movie is filled with
great scenes of drama it's a movie about
people of God asking Allah why God hates
them if they love him so much and you
sense their powerlessness throughout
maybe why so many people actually like
this thing but it's so slow and the
horror is so minimal and confusing
that leaves us wanting no sin here the
movie does get points for trying
something different where the did she
come from why did they wait until after
she laughs the scream is a sudden naked
granny not reason alone to scream so
instead of breastfeeding which she's
imagining she's actually having her
breasts pecked to death by a crow which
makes sense if you take the exact
combination of drugs this screenwriter
took this asshole somehow managed to
fall and then stay asleep last night
despite the witch kids the dead kid the
grave-digging and a sleepwalking wife
breastfeeding demon birds must've got
his hands on some 17th century ambient
okay I know they're both distracted by
the dead animals but did William
seriously not hear or see black Phillip
coming at him and if not could Thomas
and not give him a fucking heads up with
his Black Goat actually turning out to
be evil I'm beginning to understand what
Kaleb was saying on his deathbed but
remember this movie is practically
unintelligible and in that scene he's
screaming and mumbling something about a
cat a crow a raven a three-legged dog
and a wolf and I'm going to assume black
Phillip the goat is the ringleader like
a witch pimp of sorts these are actually
disguises of many witches
we see later I'm guessing but unless
you're hearing is absolutely amazing or
you watch a movie with subtitles this
went right past you and it's a failure
on the movies part not to make this
information more clear
overzealous murder goat earns a 15-yard
penalty for unsportsmanlike conduct
after this taunting dance how ironic
he died in the wood he loved so much
also the tragedy of dads goat death is
compounded further by the fact that
someone's gonna have to pick up and
restock all that pawn firewood the witch
was pretty full from all the animals in
the barn so she must have wrapped up the
twins real nice and a doggy bag of
course black Phillip leaves the scene
like a douche bag so good luck proving
you're not a witch now Thomasin once
again she doesn't hear or see her mom
sneaking up even though she was looking
in that direction
well she's great at playing a crazy
religious crow breastfeeding mom but
this actress has no ability to hold her
breath unless the movie is saying she's
not dead just really tired and stabbed
is there any reason to whisper at this
point she's seduced to the dark side
already there are no people around to
hear this except the audience which camp
cannot write my name oh good the devil
uses paper contracts when a verbal sale
should be only needs I mean does
business involving which souls often go
to court oh look there are lots of
witches why isn't this movie called of a
bitches
so she's entering a coven of witches I
guess all we just saw was some sort of
recruiting thing who knows she's a witch
now I guess going to Hogwarts
wait why is she rising she didn't
partake in the campfire ceremony she's
no that's cheating also what happened to
the twins keep that's what I mean Thomas
and fell asleep after the old witch
attacked them in the goat pen next
morning dead animals in Sleepy Thomasin
but no twins and they are never so much
as mentioned again this movie in that
ear Jesus I haven't seen a film so
muddled and pointless gets so much
attention since one night in Paris
you know the vector ER Venus this heart
is where you treated this heart here no
your honor
I object and why is that mr. Reid
because it's devastating to my case the
solar loaded up the truck in the movie
Beverly
[Music]
do I make you horny baby I warned you
but did you listen to me oh no you know
all didn't you oh it's just a harmless
little bunny isn't it looking at
cleavage is like looking at the Sun you
don't stare at it
it's too risky you get a sense of it
then you look away right leave me be
go tell mother and father of my
wickedness promising dad here don't come
back for five to seven days why my I sir
you've never used them hey when you're
the most annoying sound in the world
ba ba ba I love my dead gay son the
wrong kid died Chuck baby huh Chuck they
ha ha
shark bay ooh but then I saw the Congo
creeping people back cutting through the
forest with a golden check